So where do I think AI will be in five
to ten years?
While the possibilities are endless I
believe the most consequential will be
secure application development name is
Sridhar Muppidi,
I'm the CTO for IBM Security. Our clients
are going through a digital
transformation journey,
they're modernizing applications data
and infrastructure.
IBM delivers a number of security
solutions to help our clients
protect detect and respond,
but the reality is that security
professionals
that use our offerings are inundated
with
too many things to do, too much of data,
very little time, and too few skills. AI
can have a huge impact on cyber security
solutions
and the professionals. Since the
inception of AI
we've learned that to make at the right
AI system
we need the right data we need to train
the AI model
on the right data test it for bias
as well as to ensure that it is robust
on the solution side. AI can help us
provide accuracy in detection ai can
help in
accelerating the investigation and
automating the response
it can also help provide proactive
mechanisms of protection
so that you're safeguarding against
threats we made a massive investment on
AI,
and IBM and 100 of our products use
AI my favorite solution is how we use AI
to do a continuous verification of a
user based on behavioral biometrics
this helps us evaluate the risk of a
specific user for a specific session.
So based on that we're able to subject
the user to right amount of friction.
If the risk is low we don't need to
subject the user from multiple passwords
on the other hand if the risk is high
you may want to prompt
the user for a password or even a second
factor authentication.
We're very fortunate to have a large
number of our clients using our
solutions across
number of different industry verticals. A
few that come to my mind
are Wimbledon suggested
as well as RGS Nordic this is exactly
where we apply
AI's speed and accuracy to help
create proactive protection improve
the accuracy of detection accelerate the
investigation
as well as improve the automation
in response. We have a lot more to learn
and
evolve the maturity of AI in the next
few decades to come.
While the possibilities are endless my
vision is for AI
to develop secure applications by
default
so that they are not as vulnerable and
reduce the number of breaches
in the industry I believe IBM is well
poised to not only help with the secure
application development,
but also secure data across hybrid cloud
as well as secure
infrastructure this ability to secure
the journey to hybrid cloud
will help our clients embrace digital
transformation
with a lot more confidence.